how you feeling today there's something
done hazard on I'm doing well i didn't
know if this was your uh your retirement
tour as well everybody's talked about
Kobe what what's your future are you
planning on playing next year yeah my
place imma play until you know I feel
like I can't really play anymore
probably won't announce anything until
you know summertime of whichever season
that I feel like because my last season
on so maybe like two three four more
years something like that are you
planning on playing for the Lakers next
year of course that's always uh no I do
you know situation but we'll see you
know early right now so I don't want to
get into all that right now you know
it's still really and you know
everybody's trying to make moves to win
so no lazy did you get co be anything um
not really what did he get you you sign
your certainly fine though he's on
Jersey's Governor Kobe straight so
hopefully you have a really good um I
don't want to get him for his entire you
know I'm happy for him i'm happy that
you finally got a chance to go home and
be with his family his kids and wife and
just like wake up and not have to go to
work on vacation and dinner maybe I
don't know you know I'm happy one you're
giving away your tickets for Kobe's last
game at home yeah be giving away our
four tickets so fans I think of the way
ticket to all season up ignore list
since 2010 I limbo 2000 tender
championship we gave away Flossie for
the UH well for Game one you know so
that was fun of fans that ran someone
for see sort of today one championship
but you know we on Metta World Peace
calm and when you message being on
medical fees are on you get a chance to
win
and you know free tickets connect very
expensive right now trying to give our
fans a chance I really can't afford the
tickets but how do they win I'll be they
randomly select salt out of everybody
needs to let uh we go through all the
messages you know we need ugly comments
and we pick we try to be fair you know
sometimes we picked email sometimes pick
narrows you covered a lot of the great
scores of all time so if tougher
assignment here lebron kobe michael
jordan anybody else you want to throw in
there um I mean just like back in the
days back in the other it was on my
castle he passed away you know had a
better drug transaction you know passed
away but he was he was tough that's from
my hugs told me I play basketball and
then I you know Michael Jordan you know
Kobe bring out asleep but in my ever you
know it was called me cuz i played
against called me more michael jordan
was pretty tough although there's a
couple other guys from the hood um that
plated gates you know alamo is pretty
tough to go a lot of guys from her did
you ever have one of those moments that
Kobe or LeBron or Michael late you up
for a big number um Michael had a really
good day we get yeah I think I was 22 23
years old really really strong smart I
think yeah 40 got game I know even Kobe
had maybe two times in my career I think
Kobe had 40 you know sometimes I have my
nights yeah well I had a good defensive
night you know I didn't know you know
Kobe had great offensive nights a lot of
nights so it was great good i have to be
you know i look at many people that was
able to have great offensive night
against being a lot of Hall of Famers
has gone into whole thing and I was able
to shut down a lot of nice you know real
easy I'm said that guy's pretty cool who
talked more tranche Kobe or
mike jordan i think i think i could MJ
could they both different so i like both
of them because but in general what you
get is you get people who is talking
trash to you and backing it up but
nowadays you guys are scared to talk
trash I don't think they're think they
can back it up you know so I remember
getting in the game yesterday and
talking trash immediately once I checked
in you know I miss those days you know
where you just talk and then you know
some days you're not going to be able to
back it up but in some days you can back
it up but nowadays I think guys wait we
could i get the championship or they
waiting chilly up in the game with a
lead an HK talk trash when it down but
it can't talk trash unit losing so in
bed with toe trash losing a winner hey
Colby also see that's the difference
between a real trash called for you know
God's and Paul Pierce and stuff so we
don't really have any real trash talkers
that i know of these days he's a Metta
World Peace the lakers forward plans on
playing a few more years and go to his
website giving away tickets for tickets
for Kobe's final home game did you
factor in it all with the drama with
D'Angelo Russell and swaggy P oh that's
like you know Rudy a life in real life
always will be something that happens on
the news uh you know you get things that
happen also you know you get somebody
got wrong somebody got murdered it's not
like it's going to be the last glory
always going to be some new news
published and even in the NBA something
happen with drugs or something happen
with suspensions or something happened
with you know a flicking south technical
foul and even though it might have
happened yesterday it doesn't mean that
something is not going to happen
tomorrow so for me I always I know that
in the back of my mind so any time
something happened you know I never
really paid any attention cuz I always
know that something else going to happen
in the future so I don't care all up and
on about her sentences or refrigeration
how confident are you that DeAngelo
Russell is the right guy to lead the
lakers the next decade
um you never know because it's not it's
too early to say who's going to lead
anything you know the fact that that
type of a torch or crown and earn so um
you know I wouldn't want to give it to
anybody at you know right right now
because you gotta own you know what you
want you know in his life um and in this
NBA also i'm gonna earn it do you think
free agents who have a hard time
trusting DeAngelo Russell with what
happened with swaggy P you know while
the latest pay you know big money for
people to do their job so you know you
come to the Lakers just come to your job
simple you know you come you when you
know you try to get back our and just
try to put up another banner and that's
it you don't you don't you don't think
about anything I was not about trust
about one well have fun the rest of the
season there and good luck on Tuesday
with Kobe's final home game there and
and then whatever decision in the
offseason Thank You Metta good to talk
to you again and give me that website
give me the website again that people
can go and register for the tickets yeah
well one of our website you can go to
the panda spring com we're doing a lot
of great days there were using the money
that we get from the purchases and we're
paying for youth leagues and different
things like that so please support the
pandas friend calm and if you can go to
Metta World Peace calm to answer for
free tickets to the last great awesome
great to talk to you enjoy the offseason
Thank You Metta a good food good night
Metta World Peace the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience